où
[Musique]
il
10le j0 le nom était fausse les logis 0
on voulait cette arena futuroscope parce
que il y avait une volonté d'abord
d'associer futuroscope qui reste ce qui
fait parler ce qui érode deux
territoires très loin à chaque fois nous
associons ce qu'il fait sur ce
territoire au futuroscope est en tout
cas le futur est qu'on parle et puis le
mot arena parce qu'on voulait kg et de
la culture et du sport avant que les
premières clermont tam en convoi les
grues
rien n'était acquis parce que finalement
il ya le jour le plus important c'est le
jour où le projet devient irréversible
en tout les projets il ya sato qu'on
n'est pas ce jour où la chose devient
irréversible rien n'est jamais acquis et
donc la satisfaction elle vient bien
évidemment là et puis elle vient surtout
parce que c'est un projet partagé
l'ensemble dès élus de la majorité
l'ensemble des des puissances qui est
autour d'eux
si rayonne sur le sport sur les cultures
tous les acteurs de ces vies ont voulu
ce projet l'ensemble des élus locaux ont
soutenu ce projet donc voilà c'est le
fait de partager un projet c'est ça qui
est merveilleux et ce quoi s'attendre à
d'autres - parce qu'en même temps on
faisait une arena future reprend
d'écrire et le futuroscope 2 on est tous
début mars 2001 tout ferme tout ferme à
commencer par la compagnie des alpes et
on est de 3 foule encore avec denis
rodolphe à se dire on va encore faire
plus ici sur ce territoire parce que la
vienne mérite ça et que la seule chose
qui nous anime c'est de faire vivre
notre territoire est au service
évidemment d'un territoire d'un
département qu'on aime